last Friday like most Fridays I was
riding my bike home from work I stopped
to grab some water and like a good
millennial I checked Twitter and I
received a holy [ __ ] kind of DM it was
from a woman named Lindsay and she works
for this organization called United
Talent they represent some of the
biggest names in gaming and this message
it contained massive news Nick mercs
signed an exclusive deal to remain
streaming on Twitch let's get into this
[Music]
Nick coal chef who obviously goes by
Nick mercs on twitch is a massive
personality since he began playing for
tonight he's amassed more than 3 million
followers on Twitch
almost 2 million subscribers on YouTube
and streams - like 14,000 people at a
time he's got this extremely loyal
following and he calls them the EM fans
and together they become a monumental
force on Twitch and one of the faces of
the platform and so to me it makes sense
that now he's become one of the
first-ever streamers to sign an
exclusive deal with twitch and that
right there that ink on paper that's a
huge deal the details about the contract
itself are scarce so far other than the
fact that it's a multi-year deal but I
can't stress to you enough how big of a
deal this is in the world of twitch news
which is apparently something I do look
it's no secret that the life of a
streamer can be kind of hot and cold
obviously it's glamorous sometimes
because hey you get to play video games
for a living who wouldn't want that but
at the same time it can be precarious
you want to take a week off streaming
your or lose some money people aren't
feeling you anymore you lose money again
you've got a cold and you don't really
got that much energy yeah that's gonna
cost you - but not anymore if you're NIC
mercs this multi-year deal assures him
that much like every other entertainment
industry there's a salary behind all of
this
this comes on the heels of that crazy
news from last month when ninja moved to
mixer for reported ten million dollars a
year as of today I will be streaming
exclusively on mixer back then I had
this sneaking suspicion that this might
start a chain reaction and it's turning
out to be true it's also good for twitch
because it'll finally force twitch to
actually compete but it was only a
matter of time for these guys to start
getting locked down that's what ninja
paved the way for and that's what twitch
is locked down NIC this move it makes
streaming a real career path something
with an attainable big salary at the end
you no longer need this kind of
superhuman work ethic to avoid the
burnout that has plagued some of the
biggest content creators in the world it
was seven days a week now I do 6 days a
week
I would make videos I would go wake up
go to my room make videos and that was
it and looking back that was an
extremely unhealthy thing to do my
personal well-being or health egg that's
number two well we've streamed video
game before and yes it can be [ __ ]
brutal like you stream how long do you
usually stream for so the schedule is
like 9:30 is when I'll start in the
morning and then I play until like fours
like six hours 600 and then I'll take a
nice three four-hour break with the wife
and dogs and then come back on around
like seven o'clock central and stream
until like 3:00 2:00 in the morning and
then it so it's like its minimum like 12
hours a day so we're trying to be and
then I'll sleep for like less than six
hours or seven hours do you ever can I
get like I would stream for like five
hours a couple times and I was like I'm
[ __ ] done for the week like I'm not
making YouTube videos you hung on in bed
I'm done for the week yeah okay so we've
established this is big news
Nick sign with twitch and this is sort
of a chained precedent started by ninja
but I do think there are some issues
here and I want to bring up two
specifically first if this is really the
chain reaction I think it is how the
[ __ ] is twitch gonna pay these guys if
the floodgates truly are open then every
big personality on the Internet is gonna
want a contract and twitch is gonna want
to hold on to all of these guys because
honestly if I'm Tim the tat man or doc
the disrespect I'm getting in line
asking for my multi-year deal the number
would be a hat it would have to be crazy
it's got to be at a ninja's level or
higher I mean it's just a big never
stronger brand
[Laughter]
huh look I know the company is owned by
Amazon but even Jeff Bezos pockets are
not that deep all jokes aside twitch is
gonna want to hold on to all of these
streamers and at the end of the day
they're not going to be able to sign
every single one of them which means
some people are gonna have to jump ship
the second issue here is a little less
obvious but something I want to bring up
what happens to the little guy
twitch is obviously this sort of place
where you can hit go live and as long as
you're wearing clothes and can bring in
viewers everything's fine if we're
moving into a world where all the
sponsorship money and additional funding
is geared towards the top broadcaster
then what happens to the story of the
Cinderella streamer the very eat those
of what we love about twitch obviously
this isn't the kind of question that I
have an answer for but it is something
that I fear as this celebrity machine
starts to churn to people like xqc or
soda pop and these guys with these sort
of cult followings that give me a little
rough around the edges fall off in a
more corporate version of twitch I think
this point is particularly interesting
when you think of the guys leading this
charge ninja and Nick two guys with very
family-friendly streams if you remember
as a ninja was growing he made a massive
effort to remove swearing from the
stream entirely and create a sort of PG
environment that was more friendly to
families and also sponsors so with all
this in mind I think this is really
something to consider for some of
Twitch's more taboo creators because the
fact is if you're a parent and you're
trying to decide if your kid can watch
on Twitch
you're not gonna choose the guys
screaming into his webcam shut the [ __ ]
up
- those two concerns aside like I said
this is obviously a good it's been a lot
of years of this revenue sharing
[ __ ] where we've have to watch these
massive personalities just burn out in
front of us under the pressure of
streaming even recently with t food
seemingly the chillest guy on planet
earth took this massive break from
stream and if someone making as much
money as T foo is is posting photos of
himself in the middle of the night on
Instagram smoking by the water in
Florida then frankly something needs to
change to hoist these personalities up
and that's what Ninja started and Nick
has now continued the ball is rolling
and it ain't stopping anytime soon
thanks for watching if you want more
content
this hit the sub button and bring that
notification mel for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter Facebook pages
[Music]